wilkins will weder eindeutig man noch
eindeutig frau seien nicht clean er
nennt man das unter dem twitter-namen
braut winky also stolzes sahnetörtchen
kämpft will in orlando florida für
toleranz sagen wer man ist schwul
lesbisch transgender oder anderes das
soll nach einem neuen gesetz des
bundesstaates in unteren schulklassen
verboten werden
solche gesetze kommen von konservativen
denkfabrik generativ durchsetzen wollen
und das ist erschreckend weil sie damit
kindern schaden rand homosexuellen
frauen einfach allen
deshalb rief will an der schule zum
protest auf und fast alle machten mit
sie sind empört dass sexuelle
orientierung nicht mal mehr erwähnt
werden darf und dass lehrern die das
verbot nicht durchsetzen die entlassung
droht
die gesellschaft wird liberaler und geht
weiter nach links akzeptiert mehr
deshalb wissen regierungen wie hier in
florida die in den letzten 30 jahren von
konservativen republikanern kontrolliert
wurden dass sie die macht verlieren
werden es sei denn sie machen ihre
eigenen regeln um ihre macht zu behalten
gouverneur von florida sieht sich an der
spitze eines kulturkampfes der vor allem
konservative bundesstaaten erfasst das
sogenannte don't say gesetzt ist teil
des strammen rechtskurs gegen liberale
errungenschaften der vergangenen
jahrzehnte der ich so polen sie
unterstützen die sexualisierung von
kindern im kindergarten sie wollen woge
geschlechter ideologie in die
klassenzimmer tragen und schulen
erlauben schüler ein anderes geschlecht
umzuwandeln ohne wissen der eltern ohne
deren zustimmung
des amtes rand sogar kinder an weil sie
maske tragen er ist irgendwie immer auf
dem kriegspfad auch masken sieht er als
zeichen für linke über griffigkeit
ebenso wie schulbücher in denen
minderheiten für seinen geschmack zu
häufig auftauchen soziales emotionales
lernen gefördert wird und sexuelle
orientierungen vorkommen 40 prozent der
text bücher hat er für staatliche
schulen sperren lassen de santis
verschaffte auch das abtreibungsrecht in
florida verhinderte trotz der jüngsten
schulmassaker entschieden jede
verschärfung des waffenrechts der
gouverneur kämpfe gegen die
indoktrination durch die radikale linke
meint anthony sabatini der
republikanische abgeordnete in florida
will bei der wahl im november in den
kongress nach washington wechseln er
verteidigt auch das ganze gesetz
erhält den staat davon ab gefährliche
spalterische widernatürliche und anti
westliche zivilisation konzepte 56 78
jährigen kindern einzutrichtern
eigentlich müsste es bis zur zwölften
klasse gelten besser noch in der ganzen
gesellschaft denn dieser freakige
gruselige widernatürliche transgender
mist ist falsch jeder weiß dass es
falsch
das sah der disney konzern der sich der
vielfalt besonders verbunden fühlt ganz
anders übte harte kritik an de santis
prompt nahm der disney wieder per gesetz
die einst zugesprochenen hoheitsrechte
über das disney world gelände nahe
orlando wieder weg
alles was de santis macht wird von
seinen anhängern gefeiert
wir gehen in richtung freiheit also die
gegenrichtung von euch in europa für
europa geht es steil bergab die kultur
geht bergab die wirtschaft es wird von
neuen einwand daran überfallen die die
jobs übernehmen und den traditionellen
europäern die kultur wegnehmen ihr seid
in einem kulturellen selbstmord wir
mögen die europäischen konzepte nicht
wir wollen freiheit und ich werde
sterben um dafür zu kämpfen dass wir
nicht wie das verrückte kulturell
selbstmörderische europa sind
all die hetze hat folgen am eingang zum
magischen königreich des micky maus
konzerns störten kürzlich
rechtsextremisten die harmonie
erklärten die gegen zu de santis land
aber es regt sich widerstand in orlando
gegen waffen gegen hetze und hass alle
altersgruppen sind dabei bei der
kundgebung mit der demokratischen
abgeordneten anna escala wie stifte
statt waffen ruft sie
es kam anni hält ron de santis für
gefährlicher als dolmetscher
zu einer heimat für hass und faschismus
geworden und unser gouverneur befeuert
das weil er 20 24
präsidentschafts-kandidat werden will
aber de santis furchterregender als
tramp trump war vor allem prahlerei de
santis prahlerei und politik ersetzt das
was er sagt tatsächlich in gesetze um
es kam nie weiß dass de santis eine
zustimmungsrate von 56 prozent in der
bevölkerung hat aber bei der
gouverneurswahl im november auch das
zeigen umfragen könnte es dennoch knapp
werden deshalb erklären die demokraten
die wahl zur entscheidung zwischen
fortschritt und dem rückfall in die
vergangenheit
sie sehen die jungen leute die seite an
seite stehen mit leuten jeder hautfarbe
oder herkunft das macht ihnen angst sie
können also nur versuchen das zu stoppen
indem sie amerika wieder so großartig
machen wie in den 1940 er 50er jahren
als frauen zu hause blieben und keinen
zugang zu verhütungsmitteln hatten als
weiße männer die dominierenden und die
reichsten waren alle anderen blieben auf
der strecke es dreht sich also alles um
kontrolle agentur
mitten im gewühl entdecken wir auch den
mann der bei der wahl im november wohl
gegen ron de santis antritt charlie
crist war schon einmal gouverneur für
die republikaner jetzt will er als
demokrat floridas marsch nach rechts
stoppt menschen sollten ihre
bürgerrechte ausüben können frauen
sollten das recht haben über ihren
eigenen körper zu entscheiden
es ist unglaublich er nimmt alle
freiheiten deckt die wir hatten deshalb
müssen wir ihn ab
wie gefährlich ist der sand ist für
florida
sehr gefährlich ein alptraum er ist ein
monster und wir verdienen was besseres
will fühlt sich bestätigt auch durch den
preis für das engagement gegen das
downside gesetz will dafür sorgen dass
amerika nach vorn blickt stadt zurück
auf längst vergangene zeiten
[Musik]